in the last video we started to explore
the notion of an error function not to
be confused with expected value because
it really does look like the same
notation but here e is for error and we
could also cut you'll sometimes see it
referred to as a remainder function and
we saw it's really just the difference
as we the difference between the
function and our approximation of the
function so for example this this
distance right over here that is our
error that is our error at the x is
equal to b and what we really care about
is the absolute value of it because at
some points f of x might be larger than
the polynomial sometimes a polynomial
might be larger than f of x what we care
is the absolute distance between them
and so what i want to do in this video
is try to bound
try to bound
our error at some b
try to bound our error so say it's less
than or equal to some constant value try
to bound it at b for some b is greater
than a we're just going to assume that b
is greater than a and we saw some
tantalizing we got to a bit of a
tantalizing result that seems like we
might be able to bound it in the last
video we saw that the n plus 1
derivative of our error function is
equal to the n plus 1 derivative of our
function or that their absolute values
would also be equal to so if we can
somehow bound the n plus one derivative
of our function over some interval an
interval that matters to us an interval
that maybe has b in it then we can at
least bound the n plus one derivative of
our error function and then maybe we can
do a little bit of integration to bound
the error itself at some value b so
let's see if we can do that well let's
just assume let's just assume that we're
in reality where we do know something
about the n plus one derivative of f of
x let's say we do know that this let me
do it in a color that i haven't used yet
well i'll do it in white so let's say
that thing right over there
looks something like that
so that is f the n plus 1 derivative
the n plus 1 derivative and i only care
about it over this interval right over
here who cares what it does later i just
want to bound it over the interval
because the end of the day i just want
to bound b right over here so let's say
that the absolute value of this
let's say that we know let me write it
over here
let's say that we know
we know that the absolute value of the n
plus one derivative
the n plus one then i apologize i
actually switch between the capital n
and the lowercase and i did that in the
last video i shouldn't have but now that
you know that i did that hopefully it
doesn't confuse you
n plus one so let's say we know that the
n plus one derivative
of f of x the absolute value of it let's
say it's bounded let's say it's less
than or equal to sum m over the interval
because we only care about the interval
it might not be bounded in general but
we all we care is that it takes some
maximum value over this interval
so over
over
over the interval
x
i could write it this way over the
interval x is a member between
a
and b so and this includes both of them
it's a closed interval x could be a x
could be b or x could be anything in
between and we can say this generally
that that this derivative will have some
maximum value so this is it's the
absolute value's maximum value max value
m for max we know that it will have a
maximum value if this thing is
continuous so once again we're going to
assume that it is continuous that it has
some maximum value over this interval
right over here
well this thing this thing right over
here we know is the same thing as the n
plus one derivative of the error
function
so then we know
so then then that implies
that implies
that that implies that the
that's a new color i'll be doing that
blue or that green that implies that the
the the n plus one derivative of the
error function
the absolute value of it because these
are the same thing is also
is also bounded by m
so that's a little bit of an interesting
result but it gets us nowhere near there
it might look similar but this is the n
plus one the derivative of the error
function and and we'll have to think
about how we can get an m in the future
we're assuming that we somehow know it
and maybe we'll do some example problems
where we figure that out but this is the
n plus 1 derivative we bounded its
absolute value but we really want to
bound the actual error function the
zeroth derivative you could say the
actual function itself well we could try
to integrate both sides of this and see
if we can eventually get to e to get to
e of x to get our to our error function
or a remainder function so let's do that
let's take the integral
let's take the integral of both sides of
this
now the integral on this left-hand side
it's a little interesting we take the
integral of the absolute value it would
be easier if we were taking the absolute
value of the integral and lucky for us
the way it's set up so let me just write
a little aside here we know generally
that if i take and something for you to
think about if i take so if i have two
options
if i have two options
this option
versus
and i know they look the same right now
i know they look the same right now so
over here i'm going to have the integral
of the absolute value and over here i'm
going to have the absolute value of the
integral which of these is going to be
which of these can be larger well you
just have to think about the scenarios
so if f of x is always positive over the
interval that you're taking the
integration then they're going to be the
same thing they're so you're going to
get positive values take the absolute
value of a positive value it doesn't
make a difference what matters is if f
of x is negative if f of x
if f of x is negative the entire time so
if this is our x-axis that is our y-axis
if f of x is well we saw if it's
positive the entire time you're taking
the absolute value of a positive
absolute value of positive it's not
going to matter these two things are
going to be equal if f of x is negative
the whole time then you're going to get
then this integral is going to evaluate
to a negative value but then you would
take the absolute value of it and then
over here you're just going to this is
the integral is going to value to a
positive value but still going to be the
same thing the interesting case is when
f of x is both positive and negative so
you can imagine a situation like this if
f of x looks something like that
then
this right over here the integral you'd
have positive
this would be positive and then this
would be negative right over here and so
they would cancel each other out so this
would be a smaller value than if you
took the integral of the absolute value
so the integral the absolute value of f
would look something like this
so all of the areas are going to be if
you view the integral if you view this
maybe a definite integral all of the
areas all of the areas would be positive
so when you if you're going to get a
bigger value when you take the integral
of the absolute value then you will
especially when f of x goes both
positive and negative over the interval
then you would if you took the integral
first and then the absolute value
because once again if you took the
integral first for something like this
you would get a low value because this
stuff would cancel out would cancel out
with this stuff right over here and then
you take the absolute value of just a
lower a lower magnitude number and so in
general the integral the integral sorry
the absolute value of the integral is
going to be less than or equal to the
integral of the absolute value so we can
say so this right here is the integral
of the absolute value which is going to
be greater than or equal what we have
written over here is just this that's
going to be greater than or equal to and
i think you'll see while i'm why i'm
doing this in a second
greater than or equal to
the absolute value
the absolute value of the integral of
of the n plus 1 derivative
the n plus 1 the derivative of x dx and
the reason why this is useful is that we
can still keep the inequality that this
is less than or equal to this but now
this is a pretty straightforward
integral to evaluate the index or the
antiderivative of the n plus one the
derivative is going to be the nth
derivative
so this business right over here is just
going to be the absolute value of the
nth derivative
the absolute value of the nth derivative
of our error function did i say expected
value i shouldn't see it even confuses
me this is the error function i should
have used r r for remainder but this is
all error there's nothing about
probability or expected value in this
video this is e for error so anyway this
is going to be the nth derivative of our
error function which is going to be less
than or equal to this which is less than
or equal to the antiderivative of m
well that's a constant so that's going
to be mx
mx and since we're just taking
indefinite integrals we can't forget the
idea that we have a constant over here
and in general when you're trying to
create an upper bound you want as low of
upper bound as possible so we want to
minimize we want to minimize what this
constant is
and lucky for us we do have we do know
what this what this function what value
this function takes on at a point we
know that the nth derivative of our
error function at a is equal to zero i
think we wrote it over here the nth
derivative at a is equal to zero and
that's because the nth derivative of the
function and the approximation at a are
going to be the same exact thing and so
if we evaluate both sides of this at a
i'll do it over here on the side we know
that the absolute value
we know the absolute value
of the nth derivative at a we know that
this thing is going to be equal to the
absolute value of 0 which is 0 which
needs to be less than or equal to when
you evaluate this thing at a which is
less than or equal to
m a
plus c
and so you can if you look at this part
of the inequality you subtract m a from
both sides you get negative m a
is less than or equal to c so our
constant here based on that little
condition that we were able to get in
the last video
our constant is going to be greater than
or equal to negative ma so if we want to
minimize the constant if we want to get
this as low of a bound as possible we
would want to pick c is equal to
negative ma that is the lowest possible
c that will meet these constraints that
we know are true so we will actually
pick c to be negative
m a and then we can rewrite this whole
thing as the absolute value of the nth
derivative of the error function
the nth derivative of the error function
not the expected value i have a strange
suspicion i might have said expected
value but
this is the error function the nth
derivative of the the absolute value of
the nth derivative of the error function
is less than or equal to
m
times x minus a and once again all the
constraints hold this is for this is for
x as part of the interval the closed
interval between the closed interval
between a and b but it looks like we're
making progress we at least went from
the n plus one derivative to the nth
derivative let's see if we can keep
going so same general idea
this if we know this then we know that
we can take the integral of both sides
of this so we could take the integral of
both sides of this
the anti-derivative of both sides and we
know from what we figured out up here
that
something that's even smaller than this
right over here is
is the absolute value of the integral of
the expected value
see i said it of the error function not
the expected value of the error function
the nth derivative of the error function
of x
the nth derivative of the error function
of x dx so we know that this is less
than or equal to based on the exact same
logic there and this is useful because
this is just going to be this is just
going to be the n minus 1 derivative of
our error function of x and of course we
have the absolute value outside of it
and now this is going to be less than or
equal to it's less than or equal to this
which is less than or equal to this
right over here the antiderivative of
this right over here is going to be m
times x minus a squared over 2.
you could do u substitution if you want
or you could just say hey look i have a
little expression here its derivative is
1. so it's implicitly there so i can
just treat it as kind of a u so raise it
to an exponent and then divide that
exponent but once again i'm taking
indefinite integrals so i'm going to say
a plus c over here but let's use that
same exact logic if we evaluate this at
a you're going to have if we evaluate
this whole let's evaluate both sides of
this at a the left side evaluated at a
we know is going to be zero we figured
that out all up here in the last video
so you get i'll do it on the right over
here you get 0 when you evaluate the
left side of a the right side of a
if you the right side evaluated a you'd
get m times a minus a squared over 2. so
you're going to get 0 plus c
so you're going to get 0 is less than or
equal to c once again we want to
minimize our constant we want to
minimize our upper bound over here so we
want to pick the lowest possible c that
meets our constraints so the lowest
possible c that meets our constraint is
zero
and so the general idea here is that we
can keep doing this we can keep doing
exactly what we're doing all the way all
the way all the way until you so we keep
integrating it the exact same same way
that i've done it all the way that we
get and using this exact same property
here all the way until we get the bound
on the error function of x so you could
view this as the zeroth derivative you
know we're going all the way to the zero
derivative which is really just the
error function the bound on the error
function of x is going to be less than
or equal to and what's it going to be
and you can already see the pattern here
is that it's going to be m times x minus
a and the exponent the one way to think
about it this exponent plus this
derivative is going to be equal to n
plus one now this derivative is zero so
this exponent is going to be n plus one
and whatever that exponent is you're
going to have and and maybe i should
have done it you're going to have n plus
1 factorial over here and if you say why
where does this n plus 1 factorial come
from i just had a 2 here well think
about what happens when we integrate
this again you're going to raise this to
the third power and then divide by 3. so
your denominator is going to have 2
times 3. then when you integrate it
again you're going to raise it to the
fourth power and then divide by 4. so
then your dom is going to be 2 times 3
times 4 or 4 factorial so whatever power
you're raising to the denominator is
going to be that power factorial but
what's really interesting now is if we
are able to figure out that maximum
value of our function if we're able to
figure out that maximum value of our
function right there we now have a way
of bounding our error function over that
interval over that interval between a
and b so for example the error function
at b
we can now bound it if we know what an m
is we can say the error function at b
is going to be less than or equal to m
times
b
minus a to the n plus 1 power over
n plus 1 factorial so that gets us a
really powerful i guess you could call
it result kind of the
the math behind it now we can show some
examples where this could actually be
applied